tina und daniel die schwärmerei beginnt
[Applaus]
herr smith geht es ihnen gut
na ja mir geht es gut
die erste woche war anstrengend sonst
ist alles in ordnung
es ist schon 17 uhr 15
wir gehen jetzt alle ins wochenende
machen sie das doch auch ja sie haben
recht
außerdem möchte ich mit ihnen tussis
machen
ich heiße alle cia das freut mich alles
ja ich heiße daniel ich kenne zürich
noch nicht gut kennst du ein gutes
restaurant
es gibt viele gute restaurants
ich finde das café lose sympathisch das
ist nicht weit weg von deiner wohnung an
der hohlstrasse kann man da auch zu
abend essen
ich glaube schon dass man da auch abends
essen kann sehr gut dann werde ich jetzt
da etwas essen gehen
[Musik]
sind sie herr blatt ich bin china nowak
ja das ist richtig schön sind sie hier
frau nowak
sie können mehr hand sagen hallo hans
ich bin china
stellt auch kurz dein fahrrad hinter das
haus und kommt dann rein ich erkläre dir
alles ich bin ja so gespannt wie das
heute wird hallo guten tag zusammen ich
bin die neue kellnerin hallo schön bist
du da
hast du etwas schon wieder meinen namen
vergessen ja es tut mir leid ich kann
mir so schlecht namen merken
[Musik]
ach du wirst du bald meinen namen merken
können wenn wir zusammenarbeiten
hh leider nicht
ich heiße balu und meinen namen kann er
immer noch nicht
hallo hallo ich heiße tina hörst du
voran china ist mein name ok hallo china
tina nicht ihn
so ich muss zum chef bis später leute
[Musik]
hier siehst du den kleinen raum
hier trinken die leute meist etwas
[Musik]
ich wäre froh wenn du heute abend die
gäste hier bedienen könnte ich übernehme
den großen speisesaal klar das mache ich
doch gerne kannst du mir noch alles
erklären sicher
du siehst ja die bahn da hat es eine
kasse alle getränke und snacks findest
du auf der karte ja das ist doch gut
muss ich dann auch drinks mixen
[Musik]
ja das gehört auch dazu die rezepte
findest du im rezeptbuch ich hoffe du
hast schon einmal drinks gemixt
[Musik]
ja aber er so für mich selber wenn ich
urlaub habe
[Musik]
und sonst kannst du mich immer fragen da
kommt schon der erste gast
[Musik]
guten abend und willkommen im café
möchten sie denn etwas essen oder
trinken
ich habe großen hunger ich möchte etwas
essen gut dann kommen sie doch bitte mit
in den speisesaal
[Musik]
was für ein sympathischer gast
ich muss wieder an tina denken
[Musik]
sie hat ja heute ihren ersten tag im
café
[Musik]
ich schreibe ihr jetzt eine sms
hallo liebe tina wie geht es dir
arbeitest du jetzt du musst mir
unbedingt erzählen wie es ist im café
lud zu arbeiten
[Musik]
hallo lisa ja ich bin jetzt auf der
arbeit leider habe ich nicht zu viel
zeit um die zu schreiben aber es gefällt
mir gut und wir haben einen sehr
sympathischen gast bei uns kommst du
später auch noch vorbei
[Musik]
du meinst wohl dass der gast hübsch ist
nein ich kann leider nicht vorbeikommen
ich muss noch hausaufgaben machen
[Musik]
die hausaufgaben habe ich zum glück
schon gemacht
[Musik]
ja das stimmt das ist ein süßer man aber
ich kann ja nicht am ersten tag einem
gast meine nummer geben
nein das ist vielleicht nicht die beste
idee vielleicht siehst du ihn ja mal
wieder
er könnte ja ein stammgast sein wir
sehen uns ja morgen im deutschkurs bis
dann liebe grüße
[Musik]
es ist schön dass es tina jetzt besser
geht ich freue mich für sie
[Musik]
[Applaus]